Let's try our hand at crafting another regular expression.
It's a creative activity. It's fun stuff.
And this one is designed to be a bit tricky.
I'm going to ask you to write a regular expression that matches
single-argument mathematical functions.
Let me be more specific about that.
First, the function name is a lowercase word made up of 1 or more lowercase letters, [a - z].
The function argument should be a number made up of 1 or more digits, [0 - 9].
And there may, optionally, be spaces before and/or after the argument.
So here you've got a function name that's lowercase letters--cosign--c-o-s.
It has parenthesis, and then it has a single argument that's a number.
Here we've got the same thing, but I've got these spaces before and after the argument.
These 2 are not matched.
This one has a space between the function name and the parenthesis.
For this particular exercise, that's not allowed.
We're only allowing spaces just before and just after the number.
This one is square root of x, but we're looking for functions that have numeric arguments,
not word arguments.
Submit via the interpreter, a regular expression matching this specification.
As a hint, you may find that you have to escape the opening and closing parenthesis
to make sure that they're treated correctly.